>>> ALRIGHT, NEWS IN JUST
MOMENTS AGO FROM UKRAINE'S STATE
EMERGENCY SERVICE THAT MORE THAN
2,000 CIVILIANS HAVE BEEN KILLED
IN UKRAINE SINCE THE BEGINNING
OF THE RUSSIAN INVASION, NOT
EVEN ONE WEEK AGO.
WE SHOULD NOTE THE UNITED
NATIONS ESTIMATE IS A BIT LOWER
THAN THAT, THAT NUMBER, 2,000
CIVILIANS KILLED FROM THE
UKRAINIAN STATE EMERGENCY
SERVICE.
I'M JOINED BY FAREED ZAKARIA.
FAREED, BASED ON WHAT YOU KNOW
OF VLADIMIR PUTIN, LET ME PUT IT
DIFFERENTLY THIS VERSION OF
VLADIMIR PUTIN, THAT NUMBER,
WHICH COULD GROW A LOT,
CONCERNING AT ALL?
>> LOOK, PUTIN HAS NEVER BEEN
PARTICULARLY CONCERNED ABOUT
CIVILIAN CASUALTIES OR THE LOSS
OF HUMAN LIFE, THE RUSSIAN
OPERATIONS IN SYRIA WERE BRUTAL.
THE RUSSIAN OPERATIONS IN
CHECHNYA PROBABLY KILLED A
QUARTER OF A MILLION PEOPLE AND
LEVELED THE ENTIRE CITY OF
GROZNY VIRTUALLY TO THE GROUND.
SO THE ISSUE IS NOT PUTIN'S
BRUTALITY.
WHAT WORRIES ME EVEN MORE SAD TO
SAY IS HIS UNPREDICTABILITY.
HE SEEMS TO NOW BE MORE
EMOTIONAL, LESS CALCULATING,
LESS RATIONAL THAN HE HAS EVER
BEEN BEFORE, AND THAT MAKES IT
VERY HARD TO FIGURE OUT HOW DO
YOU STOP HIM, HOW DO YOU
NEGOTIATE WITH HIM?
WHAT ARE THE LEVERS TO PULL?
WE'RE DEALING WITH A VERY
VOLATILE SITUATION.
ONE MAN, WHO CONTROLS THE
LARGEST NUCLEAR ARSENAL IN THE
WORLD, MAKING DECISIONS OF WHAT
APPEAR TO BE LARGELY BY HIMSELF
AND WITHOUT A CLEAR PATH OF COST
BENEFIT ANALYSIS GOING ON.
>> FAREED, WE HAVE ONE PIECE OF
NEW VIDEO I WANT TO SHOW YOU
RIGHT NOW, IN SOME WAYS SYMBOLIC
OF WHAT ELSE WE HAVE SEEN IN
UKRAINE, IF WE CAN LOOK AT THIS
RIGHT NOW.
THIS IS VIDEO FROM A NUCLEAR
POWER PLANT WHERE PLANT WORKERS
AND CIVILIANS JUST TOOK TO THE
STREETS TO BLOCK A RUSSIAN
MILITARY COLUMN HERE.
AND THIS IS STRIKING BECAUSE
WE'RE SEEING EXAMPLES OF THIS
ALL OVER UKRAINE.
UKRAINIAN PEOPLE RISING UP, A
NATION OF 44 MILLION PEOPLE
SAYING NO, WE WON'T BE
CONQUERED.
AND I JUST WONDER IF YOU HAVE A
GUY LIKE PUTIN, WHO IS NOT
WILLING TO BUDGE, AND HAVE THIS
NATION THAT SAYS NO, WE'RE NOT
GOING TO LET YOU COME IN HERE,
WHERE THIS GOES NEXT.
>> WELL, WHAT IT TELLS YOU IS
THAT THE WAR AFTER THE WAR, THE
STRUGGLE AFTER THE MILITARY
CONFLICT PROPER IS GOING TO BE
VERY, VERY DIFFICULT, LONG FOR
THE RUSSIANS.
BY WHICH I MEAN EVEN IF THE
RUSSIAN FORCES ARE ABLE TO TAKE
CITIES LIKE KYIV, BY WHICH I
MEAN OCCUPY THE GOVERNMENT
BUILDINGS, TAKE CONTROL OF THE
HEADQUARTERS OF THE SECURITY
SERVICES, EVERY RUSSIAN TANK,
EVERY TIME IT TURNS A CORNER,
GOES DOWN A STREET, IS GOING TO
FACE THE PROSPECT OF A MOLOTOV
COCKTAIL, OF PERHAPS A ROCKET
LAUNCHED GRENADE.
SOMETHING OR THE OTHER THAT
REPRESENTS EXACTLY WHAT YOU'RE
DESCRIBING, WHICH IS THE
DOMITABLE WI OTHE
UKRAINIAN PEOPLE, NOT TO BE
CONQUERED.
AND THAT IS A VERY, VERY
DIFFICULT PROCESS.
EVEN IN SITUATIONS WHERE YOU
HAVE HAD LESS IMPRESSIVE
DISPLAYS OF NATIONALISM AND
WILL, IT IS HARD.
THE UNITED STATES KNOWS HOW HARD
IT IS.
UKRAINE IS A FLAT COUNTRY, THERE
ARE NO MOUNTAINS AND CAVES, BUT
OCCUPYING CITIES IS VERY HARD.
WHAT YOU WILL SEE IS URBAN
RESISTANCE AND URBAN WARFARE,
WHICH CAN BE VERY BLOODY AND,
AGAIN, MY FEAR ABOUT VLADIMIR
PUTIN IS THAT HIS ANSWER TO THIS
WILL BE TO LEVEL WHOLE
BUILDINGS, LEVEL WHOLE BLOCKS,
YOU KNOW, THIS IS A SITUATION
WHERE YOU COULD IMAGINE IT CAN
GET MUCH, MUCH WORSE THAN 2,000
CIVILIAN CASUALTIES.
>> THAT WILL RELY ON RUSSIAN
CONSCRIPTS, WHO ARE WILLING TO
PULL THE TRIGGER ON THEIR
UKRAINIAN BROTHERS AND SISTERS
IF VLADIMIR PUTIN ORDERS IT.
YOU MENTIONED FAREED, THIS IS
SOMETHING PEOPLE DON'T
NECESSARILY LIKE TALKING ABOUT
WHEN EVERYONE WANTS TO STAND UP
TO A DEGREE FOR VLADIMIR PUTIN,
BUT OFF RAMPS.
HOW DO YOU GIVE HIM A WAY OUT OF
THIS?
>> LOOK, THE STRATEGY HAS TO BE
THAT YOU ARE AS TOUGH AS YOU
NEED TO BE AND YOU MAKE IT
ABSOLUTELY CLEAR AS I SAID THAT
THE RUSSIAN BAYONET WILL MEET A
BRICK WALL.
ON THE OTHER HAND, THERE HAS TO
BE A WAY TO CLIMB DOWN.
MOST WARS END WITH SOME KIND OF
BROKERED SOLUTION.
AND THE UKRAINIAN PRESIDENT
UNDERSTANDS THAT.
THE UKRAINIANS ARE NEGOTIATING
RIGHT NOW IN BELARUS.
AND SO AS -- I THINK AT SOME
POINT THE SECRETARY OF STATE
SHOULD GET INVOLVED, PERHAPS
EMMANUEL MACRON, TO SAY, LOOK,
WE ARE NOT GOING TO ALLOW THIS
AGGRESSION TO STAND.
BUT WE STILL REMAIN WILLING TO
TALK ABOUT SECURITY AND
STABILITY IN EUROPE.
I DON'T KNOW IF THAT'S ENOUGH
FOR VLADIMIR PUTIN, BUT WE DO
KNOW ONE THING, JOHN, WHICH IS
HE TOTALLY CONTROLS THE MEDIA
SPACE IN RUSSIA.
SO IF HE WANTS TO CLIMB DOWN IN
SOME WAY, IT IS NOT AS HARD FOR
HIM AS AN ELECTED WESTERN
DEMOCRATIC LEADER WITH A FREE
PRESS.
IF VLADIMIR PUTIN SAYS HE
ACHIEVED HIS OBJECTIVES, IN
UKRAINE, EVERY RUSSIAN
TELEVISION NEWS ANCHOR AND
COMMENTATOR WILL SAY EXACTLY
THAT, AND PRAISE HIM FOR THAT.
SO HE HAS THAT CAPACITY TO MAKE
A BLUNDER, AND W